[Musik]
diger es wird wieder so dumm heute ebay
fails mit Luca das bin ich schönen guten
Tag hier verkauft jemand 200
€ für 210 € ich habe jetzt schon keinen
Bock mehr auf dieses Video ne hier
verkauft jemand ein
Pferd für 1500
€ und es ist
einfach
es wirklich ne in
MA
Bro aber gut vielleicht müssen wir
einfach mit ein anderen Motivation das
ganze Video rangehen deswegen machen wir
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten ebayil
und zwar einem Microsoft Xbox one
Controller der wie neu verkauft wird
aber defekt ist wie kann etwas wie neu
aber auch defekt sein Bro hier verkauft
jemand 15 Mal 1 l
Sonnenblumenöl ja Corona Prime war schon
stark und beim nächsten ebayf meine
Damen und Herren sucht jemand ein
defektes iPhone 7 8 10 10s 10R 11 oder
11 Pro und das ist das Foto diger das
ist eine leere tablettenpackung und
keine iPhone Kamera vor
allem er sucht das Ding für 1
€. okay Bro diese iPhones sind Defekt
die du suchst aber du kriegst es
trotzdem nicht für 1 € oder so meine
lieben Freunde machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten efeld für heute und zwar einem
Fahrrad was verkauft wird er sagt da
allerdings nicht her das ist ein Fahrrad
sondern seiner Ansicht nach ist das ein
[Musik]
Fahrenheit ist völlig richtig hier
verkauft jemand einen getragenen
giipsarm warum und hier verschärbelt
jemand den Funny Frisch ungarisch sexi
Chip den er je gesehen hat für 100 €
denn er sieht so aus wie die Kurven
einer Frau es ist einfach nur noch
bemitleidenswert Birkenstock
original preis ist verhandelbar und sie
sehen so
aus ich pack das mental heute einfach
nicht Barbie und die drei
muskelrisse Gott los heute ich verkauf
ein Powerbank geht ein
frei i
weiß hier verkauft jemand sein Auto und
benennt es als rollendes Stück Scheiße
mit glücklos Wunschpaket kein Scherz
100000 € verhandelbar
Bro glücklos
Wunschpaket korrekt wenn man sich nur
das Bild von diesem ebay fail anschaut
denkt man sich vielleicht der verkauft
hier Sonnenblumenöl Olivenöl keine
Ahnung was das sein soll es ist
allerdings ein Tausch gegen eine Wohnung
in
Berlin ich bin kurz vom Ende ein paar
Sekunden
später wi du
was wir machen das jetzt auch zum Ende
undon machen wir ganz zum Ende des
heutigen Videos noch drei typische ebay
fails Reime was wir schon öfters mal
drin hatten und zwar rosen sind rot die
Elbe ist ein Fluss Schlafcouch zu
verschenken weil mein Freund ins
Gefängnis muss rosen sind rot für mich
ist Gotte weder Frau noch Mann ich bete
einen Fahrradträger für Wohnwagen an und
der letzte rosen sind rot es steht nur
Unsinn in der Zeitung ich informiere
mich nur noch über meine Propaganda
Gasheizung in diesem Sinne